hello everyone so i have here the graph
of a two variable function and i'd like
to talk about how you can interpret the
partial derivative of that function so
specifically the function that you're
looking at is f of x y
is equal to x squared
times y plus sine of y
and the question is if i take the
partial derivative of this function so
maybe i'm looking at the partial
derivative of f with respect to x and
let's say i want to do this at negative
1 1. so we'll be looking at the partial
derivative at a specific point how do
you interpret that on this whole graph
so first let's consider where the point
negative 1 1 is if we're looking above
this is our x-axis this is our y-axis
the point negative 1 1 is sitting right
there so negative 1 move up 1 and it's
the point that's sitting on the graph
and the first thing you might do is you
say well when we're taking the partial
derivative with respect to x we're going
to pretend that y is a constant so let's
actually just go ahead and evaluate that
so
when you're doing this
it looks it says x squared looks like a
variable y looks like a constant sine of
y also looks like a constant
so this is going to be we do
differentiate x squared and that's 2
times x times y which is like a constant
and then the derivative of a constant
there is 0. and we're evaluating this
whole thing
at x is equal to negative 1
and y is equal to 1.
so when we actually plug that in
it'll be 2
times negative 1
multiplied by 1
which is 2
negative 2. excuse me
but what does that mean right we
evaluate this and maybe you're thinking
this is kind of a slight nudge in the x
direction this is the resulting nudge of
f what does that mean for the graph well
first of all treating y as a constant is
basically like slicing the whole graph
with a plane that represents a constant
y value so you know this is the y axis
and the plane that cuts it
perpendicularly that represents a
constant y value
this one represents the constant y value
one but you could imagine it you know
you could imagine sliding the plane back
and forth and that would represent
various different y values
so for the general partial derivative it
you know you can imagine whichever one
you want but this one is y equals one
and i'll go ahead and slice the actual
graph at that point
and draw draw a red line and this red
line is basically all the points on the
graph where y is equal to 1. so i'll
just kind of emphasize that
where y is equal to 1 and this is
y is equal to 1.
so when we're looking at that we can
actually interpret the partial
derivative as a slope because
um we're looking at the point here we're
asking how the function changes as we
move in the x direction and from single
variable calculus you might be familiar
with thinking of that as the slope of a
line and to be a little more concrete
about this i could say you know you're
starting here you consider some nudge
over there just some tiny step i'm
drawing it you know as a sizable one but
you imagine that as a really small step
as your dx and then the distance to your
function here
the change in the value of your function
as your i said dx but i should say
partial x or del x partial f
and as that tiny nudge gets smaller and
smaller this this change here is going
to correspond with what the tangent line
does
and that's why you have this this rise
over run feeling for the slope and you
look at that value and the line itself
looks like it has a slope of about
negative 2. so it should actually make
sense that we get negative 2 over here
given what we're looking at
but let's do this let's do this with a
partial derivative with respect to y
let's
erase what we've got going on here
and i'll go ahead and
move the graph back to what it was get
rid of these guys
so now we're no longer slicing with
respect to y but instead
let's say we slice it with a constant x
value
so this here is the x axis this plane
represents the constant value x equals
negative one and we could slice the
graph there
i could kind of slice it i'll draw the
red line again that represents the curve
and this time
that curve represents the value
x
or equals negative 1. it's all the
points on the graph where x equals
negative 1. and now when we take the
partial derivative we're going to
interpret it as a slice as the slope of
the as a slope of this resulting curve
so that slope ends up looking like this
that's our blue line and let's go ahead
and evaluate the partial derivative of f
with respect to y so i'll go over here
use a use a different color
so the partial derivative of f with
respect to y
partial y so we go up here and it says
okay i see x squared times y it's
considering x squared to be a constant
now so it looks it then says x you're a
constant y you're the variable constant
times the variable the derivative is
just equal to
that constant so that
x
squared and over here
sine of y the derivative of that with
respect to y is cosine y
cosine y
and if we actually want to evaluate this
at our point negative 1 1 what we'd get
is negative 1 squared
plus cosine of 1.
and i'm not sure what the cosine of 1 is
but it's something a little bit positive
and the ultimate result that we see here
is going to be you know 1 plus something
i don't know what it is but it's
something positive and that should make
sense because we look at the slope here
and it's a little bit more than one not
sure exactly but it's a little bit more
than one so you'll often hear about
people talking about the partial
derivative as being the slope of the
slice of a graph which is great
if you're looking at a function that has
a two variable input and a one variable
output so that we can think about its
graph and in other contexts that might
not be the case maybe it's something
that has a multi-dimensional output
we'll talk about that later when you
have a vector-valued function what its
partial derivative looks like but maybe
it's also something that has you know a
hundred inputs and you certainly can't
visualize the graph but the general idea
of saying well if you take a tiny step
in a direction here i'll actually walk
through it in this graph context again
now you're looking at your point here
and you say we're going to take a tiny
step in the y direction and i'll call
that partial y
and you say that makes some kind of
change it causes a change in the
function
which you'll call partial f
and as you imagine this getting really
really small and the resulting change
also getting really small the rise over
run of that is going to give you the
slope of the tangent line so this is
just one way of interpreting that ratio
the change in the output that
corresponds to a little nudge in the
input but later on we'll talk about
different ways that you can do that so i
think graphs are very useful
when i move that
the the text doesn't move i think graphs
are very useful for thinking about these
things but they're not the only way and
i don't want you to get too attached to
graphs even though they can be handy in
the context of two variable input one
variable output see you next video